crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though or I encyclia soccer
star JUCO above ground crew goes better
than most Jay Larson self-diagnosed go
download this week last week here we go
again [ __ ] the crab feast
I
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday another crappy is for
that ass holas in the zone Oh
sickle-cell like I could have kept that
going doc could have done a didgeridoo
with that one the didgeridoo that's a
big instrument for you good to see you
great to see a sickle cell great to be
here with you great to be here with you
to Feaster nation Jay Larson or Jay
Larson calm be calm Jay Larson comedy
and all social media I feel like I have
some shows but I was so focused on my
pitch touching that I I just can't even
remember what they are so i'll just get
to those at another time my mom's in
town so sue Larson's entail so uh we'll
see if we have a special treat for you
down the road yeah sickle cell Ryan
Sickler on Twitter and Instagram Ryan
Sickler official on facebook Ryan
Sickler com do you have to type in
official yeah I don't know actually to
be honest with you say I mean you know I
don't know uh okay shows this Saturday
vegas i am at the backstage bar and
billiards with sam Tripoli that's
saturday november 21st also Tuesday
December 15th we have a live crab feast
pocket ever do get your asses out there
Hollywood and probably would improv and
and it's gonna here's our special to you
here's a five dollar I've dog tickets
you five dollar tickets door number 15
doors open at eight thirty shows at nine
I am also headlining the brea improv on
december twenty sixth and 27th mary jo's
if you're in Southern California bring
your family and friends out we'll get
you in there for a good price too very
excited for some upcoming shows kicking
the year off we live crab feast at San
Francisco sketchfest can't wait for that
annuaire e 23rd I'm also doing this is
not happening on the twenty-third up
there in San Francisco I'm very excited
to do that and january thirty first we
have a live crab feast podcast at riot
la damn right we do that's pretty
kick-ass and tickets for all those shows
are on the crap he's calm Ryan Sickler
calm you got something to say there Jim
I do I I remember what it was i'm going
to be in honolulu or in maui one
to january thirty it's a big it's a man
i'll let you know but if you're in
hawaii just start getting like ready now
like okay we can get over there i'll
keep you doing a show that gets in
honolulu yeah on the 30th all right and
you'll be able to get tickets and
information for all that stuff on the
crab feast calm thank you guys for
buying up the merch it does make a good
idea for a christmas gift if you have
someone that you love all include orders
include free domestic shipping in a flat
ten dollar international fee and get
that christmas shopping done early on
amazon you can help us out big time just
by using our link on the website premium
episodes are up there available on
itunes and for androids and non itunes
users on gum road they're only a dollar
ninety-nine love seeing them on the fan
page the itunes page we're now on google
play and make sure you follow all things
comedy on Instagram where they'll also
be promoting all our shows yeah I mean
if there's something to follow Instagram
is easiest like oh that's what episodes
coming out you know yes you'll see all
your crab feast stuff on their social
media oh they blow it up load up grab
these men it's crazy we had to tell them
to dial it back with all that would you
relax at least cuz they just do want
them to think it was it's our own feet
right yeah i know that's crazy a special
sponsor this week back again nuts calm
really except but let me just tell you
what i like about this company the most
is its family owned since nineteen
twenty nine that's pretty badass that is
and now it's the grandson who runs the
business now he took the whole thing the
web nuts calm but it's not just nuts
nuts candy baking goods quinoa so right
now our customers can go on and get for
free samples you can choose from over 50
options that's a fifteen dollar value
when you go to nuts calm click on the
mic and enter our code crab feast it's a
it's up in the top corner you'll see a
little thing like how'd you hear about
us and it's like two nuts having a
conversation click on that putting crab
feast and first time you go on there
you'll get for free samples I went on I
got a little trail mix I got a big trail
mix for the house and I got a little
trail mix and caicos why are you using
one of our
free samples to get trail mix where I
have a go it's for Reed to taking is
like a little carriage some sick okay I
got these little fig they have like
these fig energy squares I got as a free
sample and then I got chocolate-covered
almonds dark chocolate dark chocolate
comment sugared free PS because you dab
that's the thing that I love they have
sugar free options gluten-free options
they have we got almond flour so we can
start like cooking and baking with
almond flour because we're trying to lay
off that gluten you know i'm saying i
got gluten-free quinoa i ordered all
these things that you can get instead of
going out to loot free gluten man dude i
got so much gluten is gluten-free was
ugly but you can get you know dried
fruit chocolate covered nuts gummy bears
are sugar-free holidays unbelievable 39
different kinds of coffee in over 170
flavors unbelievable they have gift
baskets tins buckets and nuts student
how bad could use a bucket and nuts
around you know I love nuts right now I
customers get for free samples choose
from over 50 options fifteen dollar
value when you click on the upper right
where the two nuts are talking and
typing crab feast go to nuts calm and
you will not regret it right to your
door man speaking of nuts one of the
nutty guys ever met my life but he's one
of the funniest dudes I think we've said
this before there are guys that are
funny on stage as guys fronted off stage
and this dude's lays below them absolute
oak to have him back on the crab feast
mr. Sam Tripoli welcome back to the
crappy said how to belay good to be back
in the saddle good to be back was that
when I write on the flyer crab fest crab
fest yeah I was telling them we have a
press pass we have a show mess that up
on uh on Saturday November 21st at Vegas
yeah I'm very excited I am to I'm glad
word I love gigging with you dude just a
turd I know it's good time I told you
yeah this Saturday yeah don't say it was
crab fest on the post i was like
triplets craft feature like god damn it
so you fix it it comes back and it says
november 20 20 years or 40 ft idea Julia
no yeah nobody a first 20th 21st 24 and
then we got to fix that but then when he
fixed that then he's like it got
double-booked man are you available
please say you're available saturday
who's the side I've literally had the
micromanage every moment of their bat
fest again this rogue day together we
finally got locked out but I'm very
excited it's gonna be me and you uh
we're gonna be at the backstage bar and
billiards which is a really fun little
venue on Fremont Street I know I saw
they won like best venue for music and
stuff like a hot spot waiting me Big
Daddy Carlos he's this giant Mexican
enough uh cut off sleeves and a giant
cowboy hat and of some handlebar
mustaches here on the joint yeah dude he
owns it like he owns velvet margarita
over here so uh oh yes I come to a show
out here so I felt like who can I gig
with and like you know we do we always
have fun I like do I need to talk to him
because i love the velvet margarita and
i have been looking for years for the
artwork on the walls it's it's the
mexican what do they call is bandel eras
or whatever but I michela tins it's so
awesome and they said that this one
particular guy doesn't for him and this
is the owner that yeah I'm asking his
ass where you do here favorite too I
gotta order AG walk over there one day
it was right you know I mean and just
talk to him that way I'll let them go
man y'all do dis game but the every
receipt it is like velvet all their [ __ ]
they're bad so we have a couple funny
guys to local comics Gooch Brandon Han
and then Matt markman who's really funny
and a couple other people i'm very
excited having show so we gig together
before i love watching you work your
your writing is so [ __ ] on point man
so I'm excited man what new things we
got I was just telling me I was telling
some safe driving his same [ __ ] I was
telling some st. Louis Feaster's that
you do this thing where like when we
used to do shows you have people would
have really good set you'd always caught
be like I don't know what happened and
you'll get them next time was like I was
like a triple e hug I thought you were
funny it is I used to love this cries
the love it yeah epic dump davidoff one
time is showcasing like everybody ran up
them at the show and I just go in front
dude I don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened are you a great dude [ __ ] this
truck oh yeah man you can really find
out the the makeup of somebody if they
could take that [ __ ] or not in that
situation so good man oh yeah I did yeah
it's good to be back man yeah i'm happy
for your twitter whats your twitter and
gaston at sam Tripoli samt r.i.p oli
everything social media is that and at
sam dribbly comm check out my to podcast
i have this really awesome one I just
started we're about 30 episodes in it's
called the International bad boys hour
and it's like it's with a couple of
sober comics and we just talked about
your stories of uh you know usually we
try to do yeah of our glory days of
crime and it's fun man and then I
obviously have punch-drunk sports with
Irish fear and Jason Tebow him that
keeps just grinding all here are your a
crime fighter man yeah aren't you why
was the crew yeah I was a crime fighter
now I like to commit crimes I love
stealing sugars from coffee shops
anybody else do that the other do that
our families load up I know just I just
stare at him why I'm doing I don't even
care dad I just load up on them do you
really yeah i love feel good about i
love is it a rush i did i have i've cut
out everything in my life for the most
part like treacherous rugs how much
pornography's gone too so I like there's
nothing yeah I got nothing sugar sugar
that's a feeling feeling it yeah and
eating it yeah I'm my belly caddy get
that jelly katic be great yeah episode
is this for you guys 160 rerere
something I don't really don't know you
know no guys I don't care it's up we
care i just don't know on off top my
head you could put me on the spot so
push one more date I the following week
I'm doing a nice little run in Arizona
the 27th i'm at flycatchers in tucson
and then the 28th i'm doing the side
room at stand-up Scottsdale the taffy
room doing two shows and I'm getting the
whole door that's my new thing too
grab the doors and then try to make the
cash so get out there and see Tripoli
yeah please yeah dude let me see you
soon exam Tripoli to please I know
you're working on stuff but there is not
I bet you could see Sam at nine and 11
and they're gonna be they're gonna be
different shows yeah yeah there's gonna
be some you know the classic hits and
then I'm just gonna dive into wreck shop
and piss a couple people off which seems
to be the theme of the show man you know
I like to rile people up I like rock and
roll comedy I like the burn places down
I don't you know comedy always I can't
wait that's what I told Jay I was like
I'm going to Vegas with triple a we just
started laughing I get excited just know
you're gonna get rocked when you come to
our shells you know it's like that's
really it's like hey man I just dropped
15 bucks I don't want to hear [ __ ] I
already know I want to hear I want to
rent to you know just shake the cage
especially the Bell dings and he just
comes out swinging yeah last date round
yeah you can close in Vegas last time I
close you are more than welcome to close
whatever you want well it's totally up
to you I close lice are you figuring out
the day of when we get into some [ __ ]
you know I just don't want to think that
I feel like I got I'll I don't mind I'm
happy with either one did um so look I
think mooch should close man mooch gutes
yeah like Gooch close can you know this
man it's like I've been doing I you know
you kind of grow older you kind of look
back a lot of stuff you go and I'm like
I've been thinking like I've done a lot
of DVD you know television show stand up
and all this [ __ ] like and like some of
the monsters people have made me follow
that at the time I didn't realize what
like I just know you can yeah but still
dude like the level difficulties
ridiculous dude like I've ever get a
chance go watch chocolate sundaes live
from the Sunset Strip and it's just it's
literally it should be called Sam
Tripoli and black millionaires that's
what it should be called cuz it's like
Kevin hard um and I had to follow um
what's-his-name [ __ ] what's the crazy
[ __ ] guy oh god why can't remember
his name Hannah Hannah huh what's the
comic the really crazy one that brings
guns everywhere okay Williams I the fall
Katt Williams doing home a murder yet
course
who the [ __ ] go follow that it's like
oh it's me and I go up there and I'd
kill but to this day I have no clue how
I filed that you know why because I i
bombed a montreal like two years earlier
and I was so angry at that because I've
been put in a situation I in my showcase
I tapped into something that I I now own
but then I didn't know what it was yeah
you know when kind of Superman kind of
flies for the first things like what the
[ __ ] is that you know I tapped into this
thing that I understand out but then I
didn't know but I killed in my showcase
so he had me close to show in montreux
and I wasn't at that thai hadn't even
done comedy clubs up to that point I
just been a crazy bar comic yeah and so
I had this thing right back to a roots
is Saturday yeah I'm old Apple banking
so I bro don't see Johnny who thanks
daddy Carly daddy let's ask him about
this be one of those velvet pink Glock
game up you guys are hilarious dude all
right so um we have a list all the time
we have man okay man you take 75 thanks
let me plug my share and the other
person had the file was Felipe Esparza
yeah well that was he [ __ ] nuts yeah
cuz any other room and I just hear the
room shaking and I'm like all fun and I
felt like von domm when he sees tompo
for the first time he sees the guy just
boom inning cinder blocks of my fog and
again who went well but I was really
lucky cuz a hand done comedy for a while
and I had this murder [ __ ] 20 that
that's the only way I found out you
looking at me you ever watched Felipe
Esparza yeah we had him on here and I
just Marvel dude he is he's won the best
it doesn't you and I had to follow that
guy so I don't know where that story
went but she something well I have some
we want to talk to you about so the last
time you're on briefly tell us about
court really briefly set it up because
you have a follow-up to that yeah yeah
yeah so I told the story of me cross
examining the police off that's right
process if we didn't know one
you and he's done it multiple times
multiple that's the story when I learned
that you could do that from Sam Trevor
ok do Kazuko there dude like the whole
thing is like at some point they're just
can give out a million tickets and if
you're lucky they won't show up and you
win right you know and that's kind of
where i cross-examined him do you know
briefly bring out you step you step up
and you say I'd like to cross-examine
you like I do how do you set that up
well don't do that with objection well
do the kids to watch the lawyers before
you and use all their motion okay and
then they'll deny deny deny then you go
ah pursuit yeah I'll always were soon
wrapping yourself do dudes food show up
in FUBU browser they weren't a su that's
half of it right there yeah and so in
this the first story told back and that
last one is like uh I across Azam the
cop basically what he did was [ __ ] block
me because I we were in standstill
traffic I tried to make out the chick
that was driving he pulled me over with
a flashlight and brought me to court and
I tried to keep it get extensions on it
and they did I my motion for extension
why do you need the extension is truly I
got a show out in Reno with big day
Carlos and so then I I cross-examine and
I was murdering them and she's like okay
calm down wilmette calming them down
yeah what are you doing triplett calm
down I love setting them up yeah because
usually they're just pulling over idiots
who dude that this time I want the core
somebody use snapchat as evidence I'm
dead serious I had a picture of it yeah
I'd like the law this is my heel early
like I got this off a snapchat and it's
of the cop it's other like some weird
pictures he took off a snapchat God yeah
that's where we're as a society snapchat
like enter in evidence my snapchat
account [ __ ] get my phone back no you
can't handle
vons jokey guy up letting my bad boy my
bad my bad so I basically I tell him
that he just cock-blocked me you know
the original one and she basically
quoted Shakespeare and said you know
case dismissed and the place exploded I
mean every time scribble like people I
can sleep his father goes in there go
home court win natsu everybody waiting
wet [ __ ] I'm not still you girls I can't
imagine no one is sitting there probably
even knew you could be something here
see Buster Douglas just walked in Mike
Tyson's is buggy got his ass beat yeah
the ground with nuts I needed um
high-fiving everybody out there would ya
yeah dude so fast forward I've been
pulled over multiple times since and
that's why when I always hear like cops
mean does I have literally been pulled
over by LAPD in the save Los Angeles or
the county Los Angeles 16 times away all
our 16 let's talk about why you think
that happens Oh speed well for a while
there I had a I had a red car so I got
pulled over lot cuz i had brag cards I
do i do break laws I you know I do we
should start with that hi I will start
with the Red Cross follow it up with my
break he's wearing a suit though gonna
struggle i'm not really but wave it and
by the way the red car was the car that
Pablo Francisco gave me after winning in
a cocaine field poker game that was in
the last story I told about running away
from the police helicopters you know oh
god damn like I'll go transporter on a
[ __ ] I ain't afraid I'll break
three felonies just again dude the fact
there were seven minutes late to this
[ __ ] podcast because I broke three
laws to get here I ran a couple lights
took a couple of legal turns I'll go
left on on red not even think twice
about it so I am so you that's why
you're getting caught then you go left
on red I'll go on daily no on the Llano
left turn you know when they have a
little like no turn left when they all
turn signal yeah and not a lot of people
are coming I'll shoot it yeah I'll shoot
it I rev the car the camera shoots on my
eyes oh and I'll just gun it didn't then
I run and you go you've getting caught
quite a bit it sounds like God good well
I'm gonna wreck our yeah me at risk are
just a giveaway but the 16th pullover
was a bunch of [ __ ] / 50 will Jim
remember his 16th come on man ridiculous
dude it was [ __ ] we're doing happen
basically dude I was going down wilcox
and hollywood which is like a bit where
the post office is a dude this is gonna
be really funny because it all ties into
this [ __ ] my last story is this street
just wilcoxon ah there's a post office
is number 16 this ticket yeah and so I'm
pulling its really bad traffic this day
and i'm about to go right turn left onto
el centro which is you know
perpendicular to its going east-west
where wilcox go north south and i'm
heading south on on it and I'm going to
turn in to an El Centro and I go to make
the turn there's no signs they cut the
whole street off so I can't turn into
their oncoming traffic coming at me
traffic behind me is coming same way I
have to shoot this way so I shoo-in to
have to you have to or else a mug ahead
we're driving what are you driving I'm
driving my my outlander my mitsubishi
outlander red no it's white all right
this one's white but I'm not easily
invisible yeah it's my invisible jet man
redman so I shoot to the middle and I'm
trying to get in but because it's la
anytime there's an opening some we're
gonna kiss ya ya so there's known there
and I keep edging up and I see a cop
there and I flip i freak out like
[ __ ] cops number 16 under sink so I hit
it I hit the gas they tried to find
someone know so I'm like please don't
turn around son I here and I'm not the
traffic was so bad that this guy
literally had to do a 16-point turn like
to get you yeah the turn back around so
he turns around and he picks me up and
he writes me on thanks you up when he
basically pulls me over it pulls me over
to this thing and my dog's going nuts
and uh he read gives me my thing so I go
into action dude I start gathering
evidence you know so i go i pull I pull
out I go back around I do video of
everything i'm taking pictures of
everything rap jazz now i'm not snapchat
I'm taking I [ __ ] what is it I wasn't
called I um when i subpoenaed my
girlfriend okay yeah you should be
brought her with you i subpoenaed are
you allowed to subpoena i subpoena my
girlfriend or yeah she shows up so then
I uh I basically I cross-examine I set
him up did I set him up man I guess a
hold on his thing oh now you get the
court and you just walk right up no you
get the court all you do is this you
pray don't show up don't you write
virtually don't show up though and in
walks the officer and I knew it was him
because he's the only black officer
there and he had pulled me over and I I
tried to be nice with him and his this
guy did this guy know your record yeah
he should have looked it up should know
that by the way the betty i'm at the end
of the story the judge says the best
thing in okay i want to know how in the
hell you still have a license with all
these times do it hold on a licensed
driver to practice law which one I want
to know when you were about to like make
your case you take a sip of water what's
your wish grandma yeah I sit back go
float I what do you go man yeah I just
sit there and I just talked to God I go
get me through this one man just give me
through one except ripping a [ __ ] no I'm
not hear tell you're on the air don't
take the phone call so uh we walk up and
I I'm I gotta set him up I gotta kill
his credibility that's what I gotta do
so if you have to you have to tell the
judge you want to do this you have to
say I'd like to cross-examine yeah or do
you just start walking
yes okay okay he goes mr. tripley what's
gosh she owes ah she interviews the
police officer to he states the facts
that as he interprets them I did a
26-point turn that's very good and dude
I'm Armenian I'm just listened to him
and I'm starting to get fire my blood
cuz i know he's the light the cops will
live had him live before we've all seen
the videos so totally [ __ ] lie and
they'll say to him remember that you
know what I mean like yeah I don't both
the biggest things like not to give them
anything that they can remember from the
you know not to give him any kind of
information will jog their memory so he
basically States is going on and what I
establish with him is like how the
traffic was moving and what I want to
establish was was the traffic moving
east the wet or west to east
free-flowing and he goes yes it was free
flowing everybody was moving well it
couldn't be because the street was
crossed off you know I saw hit that and
I go take my pictures I start basically
throw him in air and now I hand it to
the girl she looks at it and then I have
a video on my iPad she wouldn't take
that into [ __ ] consideration notice
you could take that in evidence no cuz
you have to have a CD dude and they will
unless it's on the CD mr. chairman this
is a bunch of strippers on a poles you
don't stand up you have anything with
the case during the case mr. travel
that's not real you take a look at it so
I establish that he's full of [ __ ] and
then I crossed a my girlfriend the judge
says I'm getting a little too over
actually like sir you need to calm down
because he I'm going for the kill you
know Sam gangs I I see number 13 come in
the big 13 victory so I cross them and I
cross enemy she a [ __ ] on you've won 13
of the 16 yeah Jesus crap envelope I
told you that I could I did I remember
the number yeah our team victories he
got enough from Feinstein special and
wiggle become a more dude I'm a playoff
team if I'm going to the playoffs you're
a
[ __ ] franchise yeah for like the
playoffs dude so I cross-examine him I
established that he uh didn't see it
that he couldn't have known any and that
there was no way I could make the term
she felt I was getting a little too
aggressive has me sit down literally
goes through the entire rest of the day
of every other case until there's nobody
left this copy just what were you
telling her well every time he'd lie i
get excited oh your honor your honor
your honor your honor yeah you know okay
Your Honor dismiss your honor dead care
you know dismiss the strike those
comments and she liked you know no
that's not happening and then she had me
sit down and at the end she brings her
back up she owes mr. tripley I gotta be
asking you did everything you could to
make it me want to find you guilty in
this but um and this is the best line
due to your extraordinary driving record
very clean record and the fattening the
eyes of justice I dismissed the case Wow
and there was no one there to go nuts
though if nobody everybody your thunder
cuz i got like 250 back did I get it yes
and now I'm I'm 13-3 in traffic court 13
and 3 did you fight those other three
did you lose those yeah I lost that
though I one guy lied one guy like the
police officer la I almost don't want to
say this because it's a money idea and I
just want to ever know I have rights to
it but I see a TV show here where it's
sam Tripoli defends you in traffic court
yeah traffic over Sam Tripoli let me
that'd be amazing day little bit oh the
13 in three men first place de FC yeah
when I wit roads coming through trip
Lisa home we're gonna rest of our
starters soon 18 and three I'm telling
you I didn't know you could do that but
I one time in Maryland I got a ticket
and the cop said I was going west when I
was going east and and I didn't cross
examine but I said to the judge I said
none of that's correct you know like I
was I wasn't in a blue car I was in a
red car well she's like well there's
your first mistake yeah and then you
know and they didn't care I still got
the ticket because you got to you got
you out here a cop
didn't show and that's the first time I
have had I've won before when a cop
hasn't shown up and I always thought
that was a case this judge said it's not
and I know you should have won I didn't
win i had to pay you know that we do you
pay right when you leave there too you
know what i mean like there's a window
right when that like the exit door hits
that I've until you know the middle
right there I know it's too late but man
like it was an illegal right on red eye
didn't see that you couldn't make a
right on red and I just boomed
motorcycle cop cop dude it is so
depressing when you go to traffic court
cuz nobody's good-looking you're like is
I you think about me t-shirts I wore a
shirt and tie and I still she still
didn't give mommy a judge actually said
um she got tired of it and she finally
just said listen this isn't a backyard
barbecue this is court in the United
States of America you don't come in
short yeah I'm tank tops and that's
exactly what everybody I'm sorry you
want a hot dog or a bird I'll flippin
potato salad a little peace out can't
believe it I mean usually you think
you'd like to get a little orange
Encinos no I hate it dude I hate
spending money so what's your net
winnings then is it like I mean you
should add that up and see what your
plus yeah I mean like if you average
about three hundred dollars per ticket
home x at x 13 minus the I mean three I
lost I you know what an interesting show
it would be to have I'll beat you in
traffic court and it's sam tripley's
defending himself for his case against
you and yours and I he'll show up
against mora 13 and through oh yeah I
mean considering I didn't even know you
could do any of this I would say yeah
I'm a [ __ ] one more ticket store that
you guys love I did a gig with with my
good friend Josh Nasar in havasu and it
wasn't during the fun time during have
sensors crazy necessary animal he
doesn't care now he does not he doesn't
care he had PJ stansberry jumping on the
on the roof of his jag denting it in
thinking that was funny he was just
crazy memories meets yeah yeah he told
us he sold me door to door door to door
meets outrageous that's some shady show
various super right hey man you want
some meat
and people like not butter and he could
sell he could sell meat to a butcher
yeah you know I mean I cut that though
what do you use his father's more pound
in which you gave it to me for our so I
do this game with Josh Nasar josh is
kind of news stand up this time he opens
for me he did ok you know he's just
opening we go up it's it's not like
spring break Havasu it's all locals
Havasu you know and i did a joke about
how there's more tattoos and teeth in
the room you know i'm saying and it
crushed you know and and we do the set
and it goes really well and we're
driving back right and i don't know if
this ever happen you you ever gotten out
of tickets telling jokes has anyone cop
go what do you do but were you coming
from comedy show yeah I've got to take
it just because I was coming from a
comedy show you know why I've actually
had to do stand-up for cops before this
one guy pulled me goes what do you do I
go I'm we were just coming back from
comedy club you come comic I'm like yeah
he's like okay do some standard form I'm
likewise like yeah get out of the car
dude he made you get out and yeah are
you serious pot light hold on yeah so
monday probably all is probably a
picture you and the sun visor every cops
car out there like pull this a solo so
he's done it before where I like my
friends like please welcome you're very
funny comics and I pop out from the back
of the car and I do like five minutes
and then part of the zoo and I crush
Ronnie lose Tripoli as well those guys
that you don't need to be on the stage
Mike careful he's just gonna be funny
and I love racial jokes which is amazing
or from cops and III crush so anyways we
do this sad it was a lot of fun it was
all elderly but I think this guy's gonna
beat his wife because he was heckling us
and we were killing him and he's like
you did this to me on purpose i'm like a
lady bad night for you so we're driving
back in Arizona we get pulled over right
and the guys like where you guys come
from like Lake Havasu man we're just
doing stamp it's like all you got
stand-ups huh I'm like yeah man he goes
up tell me some jokes I'm like um I go
all we just got back from Lake Havasu
with us more tattoos and teeth haha
alright guys take it slow man be
cool that was very funny and we take off
he's like oh my josh is like oh my god
you got sounds cuz josh is driving yeah
is it oh my god you gotta stop i'm like
yeah that happens once a wild ad now
he's like all else so great so we get in
California he's speeding we get pulled
over again so really they don't worry I
got a NASA goes dude dude again do it
again do it again I'm like dude I don't
know man you're asking for lightning to
strike twice please man to be honest I
can't get this tick I'm like okay so it
meets the Selma yeah I got me I got
[ __ ] New York TiVo's in the
background a little wastey read this is
baked potatoes in here so he pulls us
over man and uh he's like dude cam did
to do it again please please please I go
I'll try dude I don't know man you get
the the window goes I was like what do
you guys get into Nash's like oh we're
just calms got back from have sooo where
there's more teeth and tattoos I'm like
he ripped your bed I'm like you just
[ __ ] not only did you rip my bae you
[ __ ] it up man the cop comes back gives
them a tick I'm like that's what you
[ __ ] flip your steel and [ __ ]
material you [ __ ] tickets for
junior friends jokes badly [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh man I can totally see that
going down um to this day still talks
about how you jack my [ __ ] I won't hear
about this one right here I don't even
know what to say what is this I'll
prompt stock yeah what is that ah you
know to the eye I spell it right PR um
because not what is it it's prompt stump
ok / oh I uh I was when I lived in vegas
like i used to get i would take any gig
I was so desperate for stage time and
when I started doing stand-up we kind of
were talking before the show started
that like the the stamp scene was
started by by uh in Las Vegas to start
by doug stanhope pretty much he's seen
as Godfather then the next generation
was you know jo koy and myself and when
I started doing stand-up in Vegas there
was one open mic every other week in the
entire city for local cop one open mic
oh so I'm like hey man I'm just gonna I
got start my own scene cuz no matter
where you start you always hear New York
City comes get up five
x a nightmare picking up all the time
dude you gotta get up more I'm like [ __ ]
I gotta get up a lot so what i would do
is i started my own comedy basically my
own scene where I every night I found a
different bar and I would do I would
sorry I go what's your slow night to be
like this and I'm like give me the night
I'm gonna do a stand-up show there and I
did it like every night I ended up
having like four shows a week off the
strip one show week on the strip having
three improv shows in the station
casinos off you know so I was gigging
everywhere all the time and but i would
get weird gigs and someone called me
they asked me if I want to do / on stock
okay and we're like okay it's in prop
Nevada now if you don't know anything
about problem about it's literally the
only county in the country where
everything is legal okay you
prostitution drugs whatever you want to
do it goes that's where Lamar Odom got
busted oh he's in pahrump okay dhoom big
dick pills and [ __ ] I mean that's
[ __ ] you money when you drop 70k in a
hook inaudible I don't even know what is
that we would draw he drops seventy
thousand dollars over weekend for [ __ ]
ass is that he got bus was with a [ __ ]
he's doing a ball cocaine God and got
his wife back that's balling right there
when you [ __ ] a [ __ ] and dude big dick
pills and get your wife back I heard I
heard I mean I heard it all that went
down but I didn't know details of that
that's [ __ ] crazy so I to wait so
this is where you're going we're going
to prom this town ok so prompt stock was
on a ah it was on this guy's farm and it
but it was like a weird farm charm
mulatto what are you growing roses fan
yeah is it was actually got the name of
the word for it but it was like it was
in a farm it was like a fenced off like
a really like barbed wire fence dup farm
and it was crazy we're driving down this
road in this van it was me my buddy
bidding
mr Mackey oh dude Keith Healy mark
hatchell and this guy named Matt and
Matt was just a random guy that was kind
of hanging out with us and we drive down
and it was a guy named Malcolm it I was
a car that's what I was like my mom
pound it wasn't even scary yeah we just
like a chance [ __ ] the farm and had a
compound that's what I could you know
it's like it's like all right this
people like just living the way they
want to live that's it is it's yeah it's
like free lights like this crazy like we
get there and on the you know you're in
a place when there's a loudspeaker
system and he goes if you go off the
premises we cannot guarantee your safety
please stay on the premises I'm like
where the [ __ ] are we so we get there
and it's just it's called prom stock and
it's just this hillbilly any he's like
you guys are comics I'm like yeah he's
like come on in and we go into his house
he goes I just want to let you know what
this whole event is about prom stock
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
raise money so I could build a rocket
right spaceship this is all true that
runs on human fecal matter man and I
knew it's real because he had a diagram
of it on the wall like he's like this
rocket pointing removes yet it was just
written is like a Michael Mann we're
gonna raise money man I'm gonna build
this rock out of the designs and
everything and we're gonna go to space
I'm running on a rock it runs on poop
and I was like oh my god this is the
craziest gig ever dude we we go out
there there's about 50 people at this
gig and live in this cop out no let's
live all over the place but you know
there's Outsiders coming in they want an
item I interview this guy's like I'm
like have you ever met slept late
relatives is like yeah my cousin I
hooked up my cousin that's a true story
and this everybody looks like uh-uh the
hillbillies from WWE membered
hey Jim yeah that's what the overalls ah
no teeth everybody's on math before math
was cool you know what I'm saying like
they were on before it was cool but
before that he was doing here and all my
friends go up and we're just all eating
we're eating it and I go up there and I
start doing really well and but they
start heckling me and I start killing
them and I remember they're like who are
you and I go I'm you know I'm from the
NRA man the NRA has sent us and we want
to support your cause get you guys in
the space and I start getting crushing
after that I mean I just [ __ ] crush I
mean crushing 50 hillbillies like Katt
Williams at the Apollo just going
[ __ ] nuts right so our prom stock was
like Woodstock and that there were drugs
everywhere I mean any country people
forget everybody bought the drugs it was
like a potluck you know what I'm saying
potluck of drugs a little drugs here
little drugs there this one guy has
liquid acid am I ever done liquid I've
never done acid but I've heard of liquid
ass yeah it's heard of it yeah it's
grown man [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
so Matt decides he wants to go do two
hits of liquid acid so it goes and he
buys the liquid acid and he eats it and
he comes he also a comic or he's just a
random guy he's a random friend of ours
driving the maze honey now okay you're
pressing on he's a prompt stop when I
[ __ ] you making 51 playa I'm coming so
you got overalls man so Matt comes over
while just hanging out just taking in
the moment and we're just talking about
the show and matt is like um Matt sack
man I don't feel anything I'm I did you
really gotta give it sometimes like nah
man I don't feel [ __ ] I'm like dude it's
like you just took it and it's a classic
thing with drug acts when they just take
something it's not instant [ __ ] I'm like
do give it some time and he's like no
I'm gonna go say something to the drug
dealer which is like you know drug
dealers love customer feedback they
really love ya Bucky on account yeah
four stars you know so uh Matt walks up
and I watched this happen
and I think the guy just base Lee's like
what the [ __ ] it takes like the bottle
pours it down Matt's throw Matt's like
got a shitload well as I'm watching this
[ __ ] thing my friends are you know
buying mushrooms this giant bag of
mushrooms like it literally looked like
a pregnant chipotle [ __ ] burrito just
of just [ __ ] shrooms just giant and
we're all eating shrooms and Matt comes
back and Matt's like it's starting to
hit him you know what I'm saying and he
just freaks out he grabs the bag of
shrooms and just starts oh my bad [ __ ]
it just starts eating them so we're like
[ __ ] Matt you are [ __ ] I'm like dude
matt is about to go nuts we gotta get
him back to Vegas yeah that's nice of
you it is 45 minutes to drive we're
driving and we're literally going down
this trying to outrace acid mushrooms
and we're just at my buddies driving he
shroomed now he's like getting gps for
mushrooms and three runs take a left you
know that's a dancing masturbating bear
turn [ __ ] take a ride and we're
driving and bolted out of the car off
what you leave the compound we can't
guarantee your safety yeah one hundred
percent you know and it's like it's like
it's just nothing but corn fields and
corn fields like where you dump bodies
and [ __ ] and we're just driving and
we're just all tripping balls man and
then son I look back and matt is [ __ ]
naked naked sweating beating off he's
just beating off in the back of the van
just punching his munchkin just chilling
and a search yelling Matt man's gotta
come Matt man's got to come and
everyone's like [ __ ] we're tripping he's
tripping really hard he grabs my friend
Vinny's [ __ ] joke book just starts
like mad you can't grab anybody's joke
book that's a joke book
don't he starts [ __ ] shredding it
right we're like Matt you gotta stop
Vinnie punch his math math beating off
man punches him he's horny as [ __ ] he
jumps on me naked I'm fighting him off
he's like man man's gotta [ __ ] mask I
might get him off me somebody opens the
van door we try [ __ ] kicking Matt out
while you're driving why we're driving I
was so we're holding on it's like a
James Bond film with people guys try to
kick my naked this does he have a boner
no he's [ __ ] tripping balls he just
wants to beat off and it we just keep
going man and we eventually get get him
off me we said we hold him down we're
just holding him down he's freaking out
we hold them down and it's like a 30
minute drive we get to Vegas we get
outside our friends our neighborhood we
opened always like [ __ ] it out and he
just brought any such running through
the neighborhood naked right he said
what but he's not just trying he's
whacking off as he's running oh yeah
balls right she's tripping I mean bald
is okay I kids out with a gun puts it on
its goddamn pervert the Cossacks look at
we don't hear from him for like two days
and it turns out he ended up in in jail
I'm not jail in the hospital I mean how
long would that trip last I know but we
know I wasn't it did laughs for two day
I mean he was on a lot of [ __ ] I was
gonna say poured that poured that bottle
in and then all the shrooms yeah I mean
he went level nine [ __ ] nine dude
just [ __ ] Gandhi and yeah did he step
back from that and we never heard from
him again we never saw
probably it's probably a a means go let
me tell you about the time where he is
Moon Man even with the prompt stock you
get that [ __ ] to shovel I never knew
what happened on my [ __ ] shuttle the
[ __ ] shuttle to outer space and that was
it man we never run turns man for him
again did we never heard from him again
I got that speaking of naked you had
said you talked about seeing your dad
naked I wanted to hear about this yeah
Mike I love my father I don't have a
clue what my dad does for money i call
him his he says he's at the office which
is whatever Indian casino he's gambling
at that time that's always been my
daddy's here if he lives in Prescott
Arizona I Neela his dream has been to
live in arizona and just gamble that's
all I ever wanted to do as a kid that's
right here in Miami I'm gonna move the
Arizona someday real like we live here
as I'm going Arizona and he he went
there he lives with is a black
girlfriend who used to dance on Soul
Train which is a true story I'm every
thumb yeah she used to she danced she
does the funky chicken and stuff she's
like that's her big claim to fame she's
a very nice woman Brenda and I'm very
happy she's in my dad's life but my dad
is right you know he's a great guy but
he's he's just he's just crazy i have a
crazy father i love to death and he was
a great dad ah but he's a little on
self-aware sometimes so uh I did this
for a funny story so so I I remember one
time in Phoenix and then I'll lead into
my dad and then I one time I was gigging
with the Maz Jobrani and some of the
best gigs I've ever had my life were
with maz jobrani cuz whenever he shows
up anywhere the whole Persian community
comes out and he's like pelvis icon
Persian Elvis right he just shows up
we're doing the celebrity theater in
Phoenix Arizona which is theater and
around and and the axis of evil at the
time I was part of it I was the original
one and I got kicked out and because i
was too Americanized and I'm Armenian
we're not really middle Easterns but you
know we're all the same man and add a
red car what's a red car and I was
driving a red car so ah we go there we
do this cake well
had a mad is being followed by this a
reporter from Ohio and she just
basically wants to bang a med and a med
whoa-ah banger cuz you know at the time
was getting nines and tens and she was
like God la6 you know what I'm saying it
was just rated my right where I like it
you know I'm Sam and I'm not that daddy
likes you know so once she realizes she
couldn't um once you realize she
couldn't get a match he starts hitting
on me and in front of everybody she's
you know licking my ears and trying to
like [ __ ] give me rock hard and all
this stuff and I in front of everybody
oh but we're driving around in phantoms
like what I what are phantoms right
rolls-royce yes phantoms he's too crazy
Persian show up like please let us drive
you around with like and phantoms like
yes please please please let us drive
you around in phantoms so what one was a
phantom one was a high-end mercedes-benz
so they're driving us around she's just
trying to you know get me rock hard ah
she searched you know making out my ear
and everything we pull into this place
and everybody everybody goes inside and
she starts fooling around me and like
next thing you know we're in this
phantom and we're [ __ ] right we're
[ __ ] in this phantom hi but she's a
[ __ ] squirter and it's just like I
brought a sprinkler system inside this
fun wrote in the fan doors I'm like so
so why did you get kicked off the tour
scope so next you know there's a [ __ ]
goes but you 15 [ __ ] goddamn opposed his
house there's a knock on the door these
two persons like please sir please
[ __ ] the Mercedes do not you really
was yeah please over there don't stop
[ __ ] jump i miss i bring her over and
we start boning in the mercedes days
like please don't [ __ ] I'm like just
bring me home you know bring me back to
my apartment so whenever my dad I ever
time i do arizona i invite my father to
see me and you know i never know how
much money my dad is making cuz he
doesn't have any normal jobs he's just
what was his job when you're growing up
he was a teacher at he owned real estate
and then kind of retired from that and
he's kind of was nomadic for a while
he's just like going around banging
chicks all over the country living with
them and that money up or them he'd move
on and then he made his way to Arizona
and so he's living in prompt from I'm
not proper in Prescott and I'm like hey
come hang out with me I have a giant
hotel room I you can stay with me so he
shows up and uh he's hanging out and I
so funny i brought him my day I brought
my dad to the show at the celebrity
theater and my des I'm watch me do snap
he's just killing the buffet just like
everybody just like everybody else is
talking I got a CD just [ __ ] creating
everything inside like dad you're
[ __ ] embarrassing me he's a good luck
up there he's just like eating
everything that's where you get the
steal and sugar for ya what I'm sure yet
and my dad's a great guy if you ma'am
he's a great guy don't want pain but
he's a little crazy so after show I'm
like dad go home so he I pay for a taxi
home I come on bring this chick I'm like
dad this chick is hang out with me stay
in this [ __ ] room ok I got to take
care of business in the other room right
the hotel room you get with two bedroom
there's uh there's a giant giant living
room and a giant bedroom my dad's a
bedroom there's two beds in the bedroom
and uh so I could I go stay why is this
one all wet yeah so I go in the living
room I shut the door I start pounding
this chick and I'm banging her and then
something [ __ ] happens and she's like
I gotta go she leaves I run I'm like
okay then i go into my room open door my
dad was listening to me bang this chick
the whole [ __ ] time I'm like no I
might do that Dad that's so [ __ ]
creepy right so the next note we don't
talk about that pops up that needs
government Batman Batman being
superheroes yes so I I go in the other
room no harm no foul I wake up the next
day anyways so my dad I don't want to
give away the sorry so anyways I do
another gig I'm doing the stamp Scott's
they'll invite my dad to hang out with
me he brings his [ __ ] girlfriend
Brenda who's a nice the same trip this
is a show later on later on and I'm like
dad you can stay with me I don't know
how much money is making you could stay
with me he's like okay brings brenda i
have another bed my room ah we do to
show he leads back i go hang out people
i come back and my [ __ ] door is
locked and i'm like locking the door
it's double bolted it's all locked up
I'm like do what up and I see Brendan
look through [ __ ] who is it I go who is
it nice [ __ ] pay for the park the
[ __ ] hotel room answer the [ __ ]
door so he's like I'm sorry she like Sam
get up get up another bid door locks I
kind of push it through cuz I'm [ __ ]
pissed this point and my desk well I
happen and he just goes spread eagle at
that one I get a shot of my [ __ ]
dad's super [ __ ] junk I'm like dad
pants man he's like what's going on he
goes into slow motion cuz he has no he
just woke up right not [ __ ] naked
right so now it's traumatizing no matter
how old you are seen your dad naked is
[ __ ] traumatizing if you're for your
like what the [ __ ] is going on here if
you're 40 you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on here right ok then he gets up
he's like what did i do what did i do he
grabs a bathrobe we puts it on and i'm
just laying there and then I I know she
doesn't put on any underwear or anything
and he just lays down and as he falls
asleep as legs open and then the [ __ ]
bird comes out again and I [ __ ] at
the see my dad naked and it's [ __ ]
traumatizing because not only am I
seeing my dad naked but now I know what
I'm gonna look like in 30 [ __ ] year
it's like some bad sci-fi flick we're
like future me came back to warn me huh
[ __ ] danger if I don't stop eating
pizza at one in the morning I'm never
gonna see my [ __ ] dick again and it's
just like he always does that he never
he just thinks cuz it's a hotel room he
could walk around for a naked and I
always wanted to use to you know as long
as I'm paying for the roof over our head
you're gonna [ __ ] follow my [ __ ]
rules so I had to kick him out the next
day and it's just like I can't share
rooms with my dad it's [ __ ]
unbearable to watch you sure for him to
listen yeah I he won't listen
I don't know why it's socially
acceptable to [ __ ] walk around naked
with other people in the room what are
you gonna do that to your kids um now no
I mean no but I'm also I mean who the
hell knows I mean that's all Derek out
of moon I told him the art of mooning
really yeah oh yeah he's in middle
school where's having great like
sometimes I'll just like in the house
like I'll just like I'll take a
nighttime like all right good night not
turn around like my ass is my pants down
my shirt style but my ass is out I just
want what I hear of laughing yes do it
all oh you do magic at in turn out to
like abla card I'll see you later he'll
turn around his ass is out he's well the
way I look what's your wife say she
likes it too don't care she thinks it's
funny it's so funny mad because like we
grew up in this like Huxtable world
where we're like oh you gotta be talked
about yeah I mean I I drove to my family
I go around all my relatives who have
kids and those kids are just dropping
f-bombs watching world star hiphop yeah
jung-woo star all the [ __ ] time man
it's just I guess it's interesting them
well I want to hear this one this is the
one you wanted to talk about your gas is
the one we want to uh so basically back
now ya know it's a it's a story about my
first day in Hollywood where my first
basically my first week in Hollywood um
how old were you 25 25 min you dear how
long were you doing stand-up in Vegas a
couple years gotcha and uh yeah it was a
couple years and we were but none of it
was in comedy clubs it was all bar gig
ya know and we were I was crazy I was
crazy and uh my buddy Scott who I was in
the police chase story told earlier he'd
moved out here earlier than me because
he couldn't take vegas anymore but he
lost all his money so he had no money so
we couldn't get a real place we had to
get a you know a weekly and I don't know
if you guys never heard a weekly before
yeah I've never lived in one it's
literally one step above homeless it you
can't it's called a weekly because you
only live there three weeks in a row and
then you have to move out and what it is
you move to their other weekly
and then after three weeks you moved
back to this week but is it like a hotel
room it's it's like a hotel room
apartment complex you know and you know
crazy people lived on this floor you
know transsexual porn stars Armenians it
was just like shady as [ __ ] well yeah
yeah yeahs who she is [ __ ] uh you know
it was so this is so funny uh the first
week I lived in uh it was so hot in
there that nine Hollywood couldn't sleep
yeah and Hollywood alpha Wilcox down
with his ticket out wondering yeah see
where welcome yes so I'm I can't stay in
the room I'm so hot so I'd walk out and
I just start walking around every night
for about two weeks I do this right it's
so hot I'm like I'm just gonna walk up
and down Hollywood Boulevard check out
the scenes and just I was really
enjoying you know living on Hollywood
Boulevard well one Scott goes work at
Starbucks and for a while there we only
lived off of him ripping off starbucks
like he would act like he's charging
them for the drinks keep the money and
at that time it was like twenty ninth
hamburgers and cheeseburgers at
McDonald's and we that's what we would
live off [ __ ] ever it was like
tuesday thursday 29 cent cheeseburger
and we just live off his money cuz we're
trying to save all my money so we could
get an apartment so uh one day I'm just
sleeping I get a knock on the door and I
open it and it's the guy who runs the
apartment complex he's like you got to
go I go why he goes you're out I go what
do you talk about your [ __ ] out I go
why goes cuz you're a gay hooker that's
why who leaves a [ __ ] thing at night
to go run tricked you just trying to get
some air I just tried not like overheat
give them five dollar handjobs right it
seems you're gay too you couldn't have
been doing anything Oh pays for dick if
you're a chick nobody do it happen so he
doesn't you could've been a cougar
[ __ ] jiggle that's a good point
that's a good point so these two huge
black guys come in they just start
loading my [ __ ] and I'm like I have no
clue what the [ __ ] going on well he's
doing the same thing to somebody down
this down the hall at the same but
they're fighting it and these brothers
are just whack beating the shell these
guys grab them all the [ __ ] I'm like I
don't need to get my ass kicked I don't
want hurt my face I'm a gay hooker you
know yeah oh I heard she's dsl's bro ok
I keep these going so he throws all my
[ __ ] into this means my back I mean all
my all my personal belongings are in two
[ __ ] bags and the black is like I'll
know why they're kicking out you're a
really nice guy go thank you it's like
yeah I don't know [ __ ] you yeah thank
you so I throw them all yours can ma let
me touch that [ __ ] ready for one gonna
crush that [ __ ] so we go out I throw
back I'm freaking out I'm like Jesus
Christ we just got kicked out I run the
Scots ah i go to starbucks i'm like they
just [ __ ] kicked us out to black guy
through all of our [ __ ] in the bags we
got no [ __ ] place to stay I'm
freaking eyes like I don't know calm
down I look over Christian Slater's just
stirring his drink listening to us
[ __ ] tell our [ __ ] story I'm like
what's up with you [ __ ] I just
find you I'm sorry dude I was of you
[ __ ] staring as he's like it
sounds like you guys are in trouble and
he just walks the [ __ ] out so we have to
find another weekly crazy that's weird
so we find another weekly we're staying
there I'm just walking around and you
know it's Hollywood boulevards just an
insane asylum it's just crazy truth
people don't realize like everybody
moves there it's an it's an it's a
sidewalk nuthouse it really is it's a
free-range cycles an open [ __ ] mental
hospital you know San Diego's comic-con
we have [ __ ] calm be calm it's just a
bunch of felons with capes on running
around and you know I mean like the
things I've seen there I've seen a
spongebob squarepants pissing
[ __ ] snow white [ __ ] her pants I saw
that one time I mean I watched I saw and
then I saw I saw Tickle Me Elmo get
arrested for like trying to feel up like
Japanese tourists I was there when it
happened yeah there's a video or so much
for because I would let well I'd lived
right there and I've always lived around
Hollywood Boulevard and dressed up as
madness Oh madman on the weekends when
acidic her lack of my pot utility belt
was real bhabhi [ __ ] yeah but like at
this time the big star on Hollywood
Boulevard was silver robot guy yeah the
guy who was like look like Charlie
bedazzled Charlie chap you don't know in
LA venice beach these guys will paint
themselves either silver or bronze and
that look like a statue they'll be
frozen skin and you collide some money
and they'll go they have a little
whistle in the mouth little milk crate
and they look like a robot and their
unbelief some they'll hold a pose for so
long they don't move some guys will be
like dressed like a cowboy like they
look like a statue I've seen him San
Francisco of seeing them everywhere but
you know what they phased out you know
what the new guy is the sign flipper
that's oh yeah that's the new solid
paint at the wheels are in your mouth
what do you mean the guys the flip signs
yeah but that's on the corner gig these
guys are like you can say this guy's
performer this is a gig I just saw video
of this I just saw video of this on
Facebook in New York guys doing this
exact thing and he's got his bucket down
on the ground in front I'm people
dropping their money and this guy comes
up and just starts taking the money and
he's bending over right where this guy
can kick him and he just gives him a
left to the [ __ ] face square knocks a
guy down and gets off he's like you
really thought I was a [ __ ] statue
and he just get this mother but the guy
idiot really funny yeah I'm sorry go
ahead no you ever see the one where the
guy [ __ ] with the silver robot guys sit
there in this white trash guys coming up
trying to [ __ ] with him Angie yeah con
octomom mm-hmm so I watch this guy and
I'm like man this guy's a great break
dancer and like I used to be a
professional breakdancer I used to go
pro I was
this is the truth David Diehl I hold on
this is out in that little Hollywood man
Chinese area this guy's where he is ok i
just kind of before Hollywood and
Highland was there when I was just like
really CDs yes when were you a personal
break ya go back to it Oh high school
dude I was pro I went pro we were
sponsored by the Holiday Inn we were
called HDI breakers they brought us
[ __ ] they brought us tracksuits and
sun sneakers and continental breakfast
time isn't pregnant we played the maple
leaf festival we were [ __ ] off to
we're big part of big story on us we
destroyed the maple leaf I can only top
rock that's all i could do I but I was
so good at it they included me in the
group right what's the top rock waist up
[ __ ] exactly what I did then that's
exactly what the [ __ ] i did so i was
doing a lot of that and uh you know i
just watch them on my dude you are the
[ __ ] man i'm like hey you're [ __ ]
great he looks at me as like you're
great too and I'm like oh my god silver
robot guy just told me I'm [ __ ] a
superstar you know I'm so [ __ ]
excited and I remember just taking it in
I'm flowing like oh how old are you I'm
like 25 and I head back to my apartment
and like just more crazy people you know
more I mean dude they I had another
transsexual porn star live on this floor
and she'd always want to give me her
[ __ ] new porno she came out and it
was just like her naked just looking
like she's riding a dragon like an angry
[ __ ] dragon I mean this girl had
[ __ ] junk for days dude there's some
Asian drug dealers on the floor man uh I
go back to my apartment i'm bout to
unlock my door i looked down the hall
who's there silver robot gone silver
robot guys living on my floor mike holy
[ __ ] I'm like what's up silver robot guy
he starts breakdancing right there like
he's Daniel day-lewis he's like always a
[ __ ] care
yeah always in [ __ ] character right I
like oh man your little crazies like hey
man what are you doing I'm like I don't
know dog I'm just hanging out he's like
you want coming out with me I'm like
[ __ ] yeah dude so I walked out in the
hall I go into his room and it's really
[ __ ] messy like it small silver it's
no it's got yeah I've got silver shell
place but it's messy as [ __ ] man it's
like I always say it was like first 48
messy you ever watched so we get
murdered they always murdered in a messy
room never a clean room always a [ __ ]
messy room so I hang out with him and
he's like men he's like he just break
dances for like he kind of gets off his
silver robot [ __ ] but he's break dancing
for mean he's doing it for like 30
minutes and I appreciate the show and
I'm taking it I'm like ah that's [ __ ]
grey after 30 minutes I get [ __ ]
bored right so I'm like hey man what do
you want to do now and he goes I'll no
man you want to smoke some crack like
wise again man I got some rock you want
to smoke crack and I'm like well I'm
never smoked crack before I did coke and
I'm not and I know the joke is that it's
the same vibe I mean it's the same drug
but it's really a different vibe you
know if you walk in somewhere and
someone's doing coke you like yeah okay
it's that kind of party right you go you
want you walk in someone's smoking crack
you're like wrong house right you're
hurt so I ended up smoking crack with
this guy for like two [ __ ] hours
relax dude and the whole time you smoked
crack all your thing is I'm smoking
crack him smoking yeah I'm [ __ ]
smoking crack I'm [ __ ] smoking crack
I'm so freaking out and I'm grinding my
teeth I'm getting [ __ ] weird and I'm
like oh my god what the [ __ ] am i doing
if my mom saw me now she would be so
disappointed and after two hours this
dude still breaking yep yeah always
getting great he's starting to shore you
started a short circuit at this point
yeah ok then show you that in the [ __ ]
they'll show you that the Transformers
movies right you don't see what happens
when bumblebee gets cracked out of
installing gets [ __ ] weird right so
I'm like oh man two hours I mean I'm
throw I'm just wigging out i'm looking
for through keyholes out windows i'm
just [ __ ] full you're still in his
place he's still in his place cracked
that's rude to smoke his crack and leave
no I'm saying you can't just leave ever
so unless you smoke crack so I'm just
[ __ ] up and I'm like I'm like I get
get the [ __ ] out of here I'm like hey
robot I'm [ __ ] crack down my skull
what do you want to do now you I don't
know man why don't you let me suck your
dick how about that one I go why you let
me suck that dick I go hey bro I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
he goes hey man you don't smoke my crack
and not let me suck that dick and I go
hey dude you didn't tell me that before
I smoked crack uh oh we're just gonna do
crackhead [ __ ] you know like hang out in
trees and beauty over there you just
stop me from smoking crack for my first
you didn't tell me it was rocks out
[ __ ] eyebrow this [ __ ] jumps me
dude and I [ __ ] throw a [ __ ] punch
I punch him he flies back and I ran off
to my apartment I never smoked crack
again in my life I've never done it ever
I've me out why ya gettin to the thought
again traumatized it was literally like
I was like that's so traumatizing and I
never smoked crack again oh my god ever
hang out with him again though I some
one more time after that and then I
never saw him again of human to another
weekly ha we actually got a place moved
to this other place and that was just
chaos to we lived in this apartment
complex where we just get cars stolen
from us all the time I just put it
together man so robot guy told the
[ __ ] landlord you were gay strip or
prostitute made manager hasn't got you
out maybe or maybe the landlord told the
robot maggot the skate stripper to
living down here I'm trying to get him
outta jail really what pharmacy so it
all worked out here or maybe the
landlord is silver robot guy if you
never saw his face pain so much mystery
tell you everything case race off while
you were there yeah ok there's a black
guy yeah yet still a robot get they tend
to be black guys yeah most of the guys
I've seen do it up yeah guys but I mean
it's from a very small pool of people
but still yeah I think how the ten robot
guys I've seen you've all the seventy
percent maybe eighty percent man while
we're right there Tripoli this will stay
in a great [ __ ] time and thank you
for coming back
Tripoli man I feel like my dad naked
story didn't do that well but besides
that you can't bet FL listen man you get
him next time I know what was going on
that ground without man [ __ ] that I want
you one more time with your social media
and all that stuff at Sam Tripoli TR I
pol I Sam Tripoli comm check out the
International bad boys our we just said
simon rex on it was great ah of course
punch drunk sports sports podcast and us
you know I'm with you in next to 21st
Saturday the 21st Vegas yeah it's
available on a ticket fly and then I'm
going to be in Arizona the 27 that
flycatchers in tucson and then 28th at
mom the taffy room at stand-up
Scottsdale so come out and rock Sam
triply men always great to have you as
always Jay Larson comic com Jay Larson
commonly on all social media Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Facebook
Ryan Sickler com we'll talk to y'all
next Tuesday